cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com from timcast.com Hunter
Biden indicted on three federal gun
charges a judge denied a plea deal
previously offered to Biden by U.S
attorney for Delaware David Weiss and
the story being by Hannah Claire I'll
just ask Hannah Claire what's going on
uh so Hunter Biden has had a long and
lengthy legal path so these charges are
uh one count of a false statement in
purchasing a firearm account of making a
false statement relating to information
required to have a federal firearm
firearm license and um one count of
possessing a firearm by person who is uh
using or addicted oh wow they got him on
drugs yes so the thing is Andre Biden is
open about the fact that he is addicted
to drugs right and we'll all remember
was was
um I think the alcoholics say it's it's
forever but maybe
um so he uh
has had tax charges levied against him
and you'll remember that about 12 weeks
ago he pled guilty to tax charges he was
going to not go to jail and the gun
charges and a judge about six weeks
after that threw out this sweetheart
deal that was offered to him uh by the
Attorney General in Delaware and we all
remember this it was a reminder that we
have a two-tier justice system in
America which uh let Hunter Biden get
away with a sweet deal and potentially
have immunity on all kinds of stuff uh
and that was thrown out and I think that
that's a credit to everyone who spoke
loudly about how they didn't like it I
think what was it like two
whistleblowers came out and said yeah
Hunter Biden's doing this but they're
not going to go after him because it's
it's the Biden family right and so uh
there was a lot of outcry online there
was also uh the House Republicans
launched an inquiry into this deal to
see how the uh Merrick Garland who
appointed Weiss and uh just generally
how did they sign off on this plea deal
you see I I just want to point out you
know when timcast.com does a headline it
just says something like what Hunter
Biden and died in done on three gun
charges I like I I you know we try to
just be base basic and just give you the
information you want to flash your
headline I look at the Daily Mail Route
Hunter Biden did it on three felony
charges for lying about being on drugs
when he bought a gun but that's is that
accurate because not all three of those
charges exactly exactly but that's a
heck of a headline yeah I mean and and
you know if you said Hunter Biden
indicted on felony charge for a lot for
charge for singular for lying about
being on drugs when he bought a gun
that's a pretty good headline that that
that hits yeah and if you're trying to
get people to understand the severity of
what it was
Hunter Biden is doing in the worst of it
this is it right here I I do however
think I think this might actually be a
distraction
when we had Brianna Wu on the culture
war and I brought up Joe Biden flying to
Ukraine to get a prosecutor fired at the
best of his son Brianna kept saying okay
so if Hunter Biden did something wrong
he should go to jail I'm like no no not
Hunter Biden Joe right if Hunter Biden
something wrong I'm like no no stop I am
not talking about Hunter Biden
this story right here it's flashy a lot
of people want to hear about it ooh what
did Joe Biden's kid do yeah but he
bought a gun while he's on drugs first
of all I have questions about the Second
Amendment and whether or not if you're
actively on drugs and you're like out of
your mind yeah okay you can't have that
that makes sense you can't keep you
can't have a gun and you're like waving
it around or something but I'm like if
it's in your car and you're on drugs is
that a big deal you're not gonna be
driving right it's about wielding and
and being in control of the object but
also I'm not so convinced it's just
because you're a drug user you shouldn't
be allowed to have a gun but I don't I
don't you know through due process
perhaps but but that's that's a whole
other argument ultimately my point here
is
the question we should be asking is
about Hunter Biden calling DC saying
we're being investigated by this
Ukrainian prosecutor Joe Biden then
flying out and what relation these
things have to each other and how they
came together
this may be intentional I would not be
surprised if Joe was like look we know
that the White House sent that letter to
all those media Outlets saying
scrutinize the impeachment don't let
them do this I wouldn't be surprised if
if Joe was like Hey indict Hunter on
some non-political thing so we can push
the new cycle away from the things I was
doing with Prisma and all that stuff I
think you're totally right I think
letting him fall for for some things
to be oh no he is facing Justice and and
the average American who is not as well
versed in the complicated uh goings-on
of the Biden family really aren't that
complicated they lies personal gain and
they lied about their foreign business
interests will say oh well Hunter is
facing charges he is he is having to own
up for things this is okay uh and it's a
way of sort of circumventing actually
facing the reality that if Hunter's
guilty it Joe is definitely guilty yeah
I get the feeling that people are
turning on these guys now this Biden
crap and like we'll pull it up I think
at some point in the show there's a
video of someone on CNN just rattling
off lies that Biden's told including
that he went to Ground Zero the day
after it happened CNN's admitting it
yeah wow and I I think for the 100 or
the Biden family couldn't keep hunter in
the background for long enough they
tried so hard like I don't remember if
you remember the Democratic National uh
convention when he was running for
president they brought out every single
granddaughter they did not bring out his
grandson and they did not bring out
Hunter they are trying to pretend like
there are no males in this family
because being abiding male I guess
except for Bo is not a good look well
you get Bank though right aren't you
making bank I mean his brothers his kid
yeah and they love the divorce and the
unstable family which is great
I just want to say
Politico wrote this long magazine story
about the influence peddling of the
bidens in 2019 called Biden Inc
and today four years later the media
says there's no evidence and I'm just
like do you read the news apparently
they don't read yourselves they don't no
the greatest thing is easy for someone
to say that something that they don't
see doesn't exist I just I just found
out his name's not Hunter Biden what is
his name Robert Robert Hunter Biden yeah
and his son is something similar I'm
looking at it they they posted a picture
of the gun form
and his name is Robert yeah he's Bobby
Biden why are we calling him Hunter
Bobby it is not crazy that people go by
their middle names maybe that's a
controversy but our hunter Biden you
gotta put the initial first he's named
after one of Biden's Brothers right
there's another rock Biden okay I think
I could be wrong it hit me last night
and I I knew I knew this but that Hunter
had started sleeping with his dead
brother's wife while he was still
married yes we start cheating on his
wife with his brothers yes and I think
she so the story behind him having his
gun there's this uh cult
guns are called Cobra and he apparently
bought the gun and his girlfriend at the
time Beau Biden's Widow uh apparently
threw it in the trash can in the story
to like pass it away from him next to
school yeah with them were they both
crap like drugs no but I really feel bad
for all these cousins whose Grandad is
Joe Biden the sniffer and then this is
their parents set this does not seem
good I mean it has a parenting expert in
this room do you advise I do not advise
no no no no none of them making sex
tapes with your husband and when you're
an elected Congressman I mean none of
this none of this well actually so I
have a question for someone who is a
parenting expert uh
I think I said it before I think I think
Hunter buying got molested ah I don't
know it's a pretty heavy subject but
when you look at what Joe Biden's doing
on camera to these kids that it's that
and that Hunter Biden has reportedly
referred to as dead as Peto Pete then
you look at the substance abuse and the
behavioral issues I'm like that seems
indicative of someone who's abused as a
kid uh I don't know but I will tell you
this uh if your kid gets some drugs
involved in drugs all bets are off all
bets are off I mean I've seen so many
good parents who better parents than me
right who have lost their kids because
you know One Toke one smoke so you're
saying that Joe's actually a good dad no
I am not I am saying that I am saying
that if you've got a drug addict uh I
just know a lot of parents out there
that feel really guilty because their
kids have substance abuse issues
um and and that's a problem with
substance is it controls you you know
and there's not a lot you can do to get
your kid out of it so I don't know about
the molestation issue
um it's interesting though because
Hunter has a substance abuse issue and
so does his sister Ashley Biden has has
been in rehab a couple of different
times and so there is obviously
something going on family I know people
say like addictive personalities can run
in family but sometimes addiction is a
response to trauma and what oh that's a
trauma 100 True 100 yeah I don't know
what it is um as the old man sniffing is
he just too close is that last
generation with oh honey come on here I
don't know I don't know what it is or is
there something going on he's got like
anger rage under the surface that butt
Joe Biden so that is 100 True like you
can see him anytime you get you
something gets in the way and you know
there's the eruption yeah I'm looking at
like a reporter questioning him right
now about uh flying out to Ukraine and
and Biden being like no one warned me
about that she's like they warned your
staff he's like nobody warned me that
what I was doing was wrong
um why is that dementia too though I
mean like I guess I guess he's been kind
of like flying off the handle ever since
he was elected in 1920 or whenever he I
don't know
1840 right right but also like that is
why aren't people looking at that and
saying mental decline dementia that is
what happens when you get slip into
those those kind of things there I think
some people are saying that just not the
people in his immediate care you know
what I'm saying I don't want to assume
that he beat Hunter up or like squeezed
him too hard or pinched him or any of
that but I can definitely visualize it
like grab and be like you can already
when he's like nine years old and 14 and
stuff Hunter calls him pedo Pete yeah
really I wonder what Joe Biden here was
one of his make his son call him that
that was his one of his aliases was Pete
Peter yeah Peter what was it uh um I can
find it Robert Peterson
because obviously child abuse is such a
serious topic on the other hand I have
maintained for a long time that there is
something deeply troubled in the Biden
family and I think we just get more and
more evidence of this all the time
I wonder what it must have been like for
like you know Don Jr
you know growing up with Trump as your
dad he talks about it pretty positively
I mean I've had a chance to hear him
speak privately about it and also you
know with his mom their Heritage I think
they're Turtle Slovakian also
despite the fact that Trump has been
married three times all of his children
seem to be close I mean they all
attended Tiffany's wedding you know they
seem to have positive relationship with
each other and with you know Melania
different step parents the Biden family
seems openly much more strained and I
don't think it's a good look that you
left your wife or your brother's window
I could only I could only say this Peter
Henderson if only he left her he
actually just started cheating on her
was it Robert L Peters
a couple times he's been on the show
we've talked to him on the show on the
phone we've had him here physically I've
met him at events he just comes off like
a regular guy well Don there's nothing
like there is there there is no
he comes off more like a regular guy
than
people who have like become successful
and gotten famous that I know or or or
like he comes up he comes up like a
regular guy more than some regular
people actually know yeah when you look
at the hunter Biden stuff this is like
Lifestyles of the Rich and the and the
drug addicted the rich and the
congressman because yeah Joe is probably
only at home three days a month grow for
was in Congress for 50 years or
something 28 days a month in in
Washington he was sorry I was gonna he
was famous for saying no I take the
train home to Delaware every night which
means
that's worse if you were a congressman
who does have access to your children
regularly and your children don't feel
like you're getting the support that
they end up in these complicated
emotional states if he's coming back on
the train he's getting back at nine at
nine pm at night so that would have been
my guess like if there was something
Askew if we don't if we if we don't have
our finger to put on oh it's absolutely
abuse or whatever it probably just is an
absolute father hunger right that they
did not get the connection that they
were made for from their dad because he
was off I think you know whatever and it
sounds like Trump in some way even
though he had these marital breakdowns
he was able to file accounts stay
connected to his kids and meet that need
for male love that his kids craved from
him and that all kids crave from their
dad yeah I think when you look at the
problems of Hunter Biden and you look at
the stats on uh kids who grow up without
dads
there's like a correlation there so
we're going all the way on that tomorrow
yeah yeah so culture work okay you'll be
for cultural in the morning to talk
family stuff more in depth but uh you
know I'm like drug abuse this this is
like no strong Father Figure or abusive
father who like an abusive father is
also not a strong Father Figure in it
and it plays into it and seeing multiple
siblings going through the drug abuse
and that's it's interesting right I mean
it's not I wouldn't call it a
coincidence at least value and usually
there's some thread to tug on some need
was not met there was a need that was
not met and really they lost their mom
and their sister was that it yeah his
wife like that's freaking that'll rip a
family apart if you if you're not able
to communicate about it he got sworn
into Congress from the two boys hospital
room geez that's nice I mean there's a
reason a his story I think caught the
attention and I think he did build a
political career off that but did he
build it at the at the expense of his
children's emotional well-being yeah I
don't know right did they lose their mom
and their dad oh man that's what
happened to my my parents my my mom's
mother and father lost one of their kids
my mom's sister when she was 10 got hit
by a drunk driver and killed and they
just receded into alcohol is in the
parents and they were basically left to
fend for themselves growing up their
oldest sister kind of raised the kids so
that can absolutely happen yeah thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time